few first-person shooter series have had
the longevity of far cry with the legacy
going back more than 17 years and eight
titles if you don't count far cry 6. and
despite its reputation for being a copy
paste type of series the far cry games
have gone through some drastic changes
and experiments over time all while
keeping open world chaos at the heart of
its gameplay loop in this video we're
ranking the far cry games so you know
which ones are the must plays and which
ones are the you should probably still
plays for more on far cry make sure you
keep it locked here on gamespot
i love far cry 5 like really love far
cry 5 but it's hard to deny that it
doesn't live up to its full potential
the game promises a memorable
confrontation with a cult that has
apparently strong-armed or seduced the
population of rural montana into joining
it unfortunately far cry 5 only dips its
feet into the heavy subject matter
instead of fully jumping in the
self-professed prophet joseph seed isn't
all that charismatic or compelling nor
his siblings and most of the game
consists of doing quests to take one of
them off enough so that they come and
confront you directly there are still
the typical far cry elements like
dangerous animals and goofy side
characters and i had a blast 100 in it
but ultimately far cry 5 wrote a check
it couldn't cash i did not ask for this
[Music]
this spin-off takes place in the stone
age replacing guns and explosives with
spears bows and primitive handheld
weapons and despite this it's still very
much a far cry game with the wilderness
and human enemies both posing real
threats to your survival and a mix of
assault and stealth are often necessary
to make it out alive heavily inspired by
the drug induced shangri-la missions of
far cry 4 we haven't seen anything like
far cry primal from the series since but
it proves history may be the best source
for new game settings
the original far cry is well
a far cry from later installments it
still retains the fish out of water
approach we see in so many of the later
games with jack carver finding himself
stranded on an island and battling a
seemingly unwinnable war against
mercenaries but it also goes in a more
science fiction direction the mutant
enemy elements present in the game were
abandoned for follow-ups though it does
also make it unique enough to warrant a
return trip more than 15 years after its
first release
a sequel to far cry 5 that feels just a
tad more cohesive far cry new dawn sees
the plains of montana largely reclaimed
by nature and bandits following a
nuclear apocalypse the game has quite a
bit more flair and style than its
predecessor and while its antagonists
aren't very memorable it still has a
knack for delivering short fun side
activities and never outstanding its
welcome the game also was the first in
the series to add in a few light rpg
elements that i grew to love and
appreciate
over the years far cry games have gained
a reputation for being wacky now i know
what you're thinking
where's my junk far cry 3 blood dragon a
parody slash love letter to neon soaked
80s action movies manages to be a little
bit wackier than your typical fc game
this bite-sized experience doesn't have
the same scale as far cry 3 or most of
the other entries but playing as the
ridiculously named rex power cult and
blasting everything in your path more
than makes up for that and even better
it stars michael bean who played kyle
reese in the original two terminator
movies as well as corporal hicks and
aliens
but to my video game aficionados you'll
probably know him best for the very
strong inspiration for the original
metal gear american box are
so how do you follow up one of the most
critically acclaimed first person
shooters of a generation easy you hit
the if it ain't broke don't fix it
button far cry 4 takes the action from a
warm tropical island to a cold fictional
war-torn himalayan country ruled by a
new big bad pagan men the game maintains
the structure of far cry 3 climbing
towers to expand the map clearing
outposts and hunting and gathering for
upgrades but min just isn't as memorable
as voss nor did the game provide the
same sense of surprise and discovery
that far cry 3 did
ah far cry 2 where my love for the
series began this underappreciated entry
trades the bright and colorful tropical
island of fc1 and tosses you into a
war-torn africa with malaria it was the
first mainline far cry to be developed
by ubisoft itself with crytek taking
charge of the original game and it's an
incredibly ambitious game for its time
aside from dealing with your illness
you'll also have to worry about your
weapons occasionally jamming fire
spreading and trapping you in a battle
and destructible environments rendering
your cover useless it may have lacked a
signature villain or the humor of later
games but it's an impressive achievement
nonetheless
without a doubt far cry 3 is the most
iconic game in the entire series and
quickly became the template for future
installments the game's fictional rook
islands are simply a joy to explore
despite the threat of jason brody losing
all his buddies there is wildlife to
hunt and be hunted by outposts to
liberate vehicles to joyride and of
course radio towers to climb however the
real star of the show is the villain
voss an eccentric and terrifying
criminal henchmen portrayed by actor
michael mando and his definition of
insanity monologue is most likely being
taught in a college course somewhere
future far cry games included their own
big charismatic villains but none of
them were able to hit the same notes as
vos
oh jesus
and now it's your turn hit the comment
section and let us know how you would
rank the far cry games and for more keep
it locked right here on gamespot
[Music]
you